the British Museum is back in the
headlines this time it's director has
stirred up trouble by saying removing
the world-famous 2,500 year old
parthenon marbles from greece to be
taken to Britain in the 19th century
could be seen as a creative act thanks
to a new context you could of course be
saddened by the fact that the original
environment has disappeared when you
move a cultural heritage to a museum you
move it outside
however this shifting is also a creative
act
technically UK law prevents the return
of such pieces but the problem is Greece
considers the classical marble
sculptures stolen and wants them back
seriously what was so creative in the
destruction of the temple and the
looting and the pillaging of a nation's
keys to its ancient history
Greece's Culture Minister described the
museum directors approach as narrow and
cynical a mindset that downgrades
cultural heritage to an exchange sale
ouch but in fact it's not just Greece
that's pressuring the museum other
artifacts perceived as snatch during the
times of the British Empire are being
demanded back to so far to no avail the
museum is only ready to loan saying the
pieces are better off being displayed as
part of a wider collection
[Music]
you have to take keeping him for 150
years
just give us some months
millions of people come to enjoy the
British Museum every year let's find out
what some of them here make of this
long-standing feud and how locals see it
back in Greece I think that's what's
being here is probably for the greater
good I just got a degree in art history
so I feel like they should go back the
models should be returned and put back
where they belong in every Museum in the
world their Greek antiquities why why
are we so generous I would keep them
here if they were British artifacts in
Greece I think it would be viewed
differently if I was Greek I would want
them returned no I consider this that I
consider what Elgin did to be theft
since I'm Greek I'm also in favor of
returning the Elgin marbles I guess it's
quite nice to have them kept here
perhaps to go home for a period because
the exhibition's do move round I would
like to see maybe some kind of sharing
arrangement if I build a house and
someone in America likes it he cannot
take it with him and say I will take
good care of it I will keep it in
America come see it whenever you like
you